hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday October 22nd 2018 what's
going on how are ya oh it's almost the
holiday season uh dooby-dooby-doo
and Halloween and Thanksgiving don't
forget about them before you slide into
[ __ ] Hanukkah and Christmas right
Halloween and Thanksgiving are the
[ __ ] Joey bishop and was the other
guy's name was the other guy that was in
the Rat Pack was it Rod Laver something
Crawford I don't know what the [ __ ] his
name was Cindy Crawford Cindy serum
isn't it great that Cindy's back on TV
telling these old broads if they get to
[ __ ] the [ __ ] serum and they don't
have her genetics they're still somehow
gonna look younger you know I mean she
honestly looks like she's like [ __ ]
30 I'm gonna get some Cindy's theorem my
hair it's gonna come back it's gonna be
all wavy I'm gonna get a [ __ ]
contract with Chanel my stupid phone
keeps saying update Apple ID settings
it's not a stupid phone I apologize
excuse me I misspoke it's not a stupid
phone it's a smart phone oh it's so
[ __ ] smart every two seconds you know
to diva up to update Apple ID settings
some account services will not be
available until you sign in again so I
keep signing in and there's some sort of
[ __ ] code they're supposed to send me
and I think I deleted it because I just
solve some [ __ ] from Verizon you
know like you want to if you want to pay
your bill online you know what option to
[ __ ] submit your DNA if you'd like
with your fingerprint so we can pass
that on to some [ __ ] Russian mobster
who's then gonna buy a penthouse in
Italy in and [ __ ] New York City for
nine zillion dollars and nobody's gonna
give a [ __ ] I want to I want to know why
why
all right if I go to cydia supporting
the troops being American and all of
that [ __ ] why these rich [ __ ] in this
[ __ ] country can then turn around and
sell real estate the people that live in
countries that we have I don't want to
get all 80 stand up here but what's the
deal they - they would [ __ ] I swear
to God if one of these jungle-gym
[ __ ] training Isis guys could somehow
scrape together [ __ ] 9 zillion
dollars to buy a [ __ ] town house in
Manhattan they'd sell it to him
no one would have a [ __ ] problem no
one well maybe somebody would have a
problem and we have to [ __ ] go away
we'll go away real quick all right every
time I go to New York City which I was
just there I had a wonderful time I saw
this [ __ ] dude from Russia he bought
three townhouses on the Upper East Side
the [ __ ] things go for like twenty
thirty thirty million a whack the
[ __ ] guy buys three side-by-side he's
getting all of them to tournament to the
biggest [ __ ] apartment in Manhattan
here's the kicker he bought it for his
ex-wife my first thought was what Jill
Jesus Christ that oughta shut her up
then I get him at least through [ __ ]
you know Halloween and Thanksgiving
before [ __ ] kicked in you spend all
your was funny about that [ __ ] broad
she probably still wants something for
Christmas - I'm trying to help you I
can't [ __ ] do a Russian accent but I
can't imagine what the [ __ ] you know
good and goddamn well if he doesn't go
out and get her some big shiny stupid
[ __ ] I mean how much of a [ __ ]
headache was she this is his ex-wife he
went out and bought her that I mean if I
was his account I'd be he was still
[ __ ] banging her I mean what's going
on here what are we don't get ghetto get
a one
Boris what do you define her [ __ ]
three yeah and I guess he doesn't get
audited cuz he something I don't know if
the whole [ __ ] thing is weight and
then you see like you know they'd be
like some giant goddamn building and
they'll be like the top [ __ ] nine
floors for a cool hundred seventy
million dollars they would say cool was
sold to some [ __ ] person on mainland
China all these people okay Chinese
right you know what they're doing right
that they're putting like they're doing
something with the toys I forget what it
was somebody told me this one night in a
bar the guy was whispering he had one
eyebrow but he really seemed to make
sense
dead doing something with the toys
Russia is [ __ ] with the elections
right isn't that what I'm supposed to
know we're supposed to say we're
supposed to repeat now that I'm in
Hollywood I don't know I don't even know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about all I
know is it's very early in the morning
and getting my podcast done here before
my my little cutie pie wakes up and I
was supposed to do it last night but we
ended up going out went out to breakfast
you know I hadn't seen it forever right
you know it was away from the family for
nine days so we're not to breakfast and
then she came home for a nap and then
afterwards we went to this pumpkin patch
it just [ __ ] wore me out you know I
mean I could have come on and done a
podcast but I wouldn't have been as
funny you know I would have been able to
give you all that vital information you
needed to know about the country of
Russia and China I mean all of that
stuff was dead on you can go fat jacket
at billboard.com I got all the facts to
[ __ ] to back it up right I'm only
kidding if you're from Russia and you're
from China and you'd like to take your
dirty blood money and spread it around
here then by all means
by all means let's have after after all
the suspicion about the last election
let's have somebody from Russia by three
[ __ ] townhouses right in the goddamn
[ __ ]
manehattan why don't why don't we do
that why don't we have a [ __ ]
commercial late at night okay that has a
[ __ ] knife sharpener thing that's so
goddamn sharp
evidently you can sharpen a credit card
with it and cut a [ __ ] pineapple in
half
why don't we [ __ ] do that and ignore
our goddamn recent history and just have
that out on the market now that's not a
red flag have something out there that
could take a [ __ ] butter knife and
have it go through for a frozen [ __ ]
steak dude the commercial that literally
showing the thing I mean I almost feel
like [ __ ] irresponsible putting this
information on sharpening a credit card
okay then it like slices of I don't know
what it was went through a [ __ ] shoe
I love the thing that's just like we
took this serrated [ __ ] knife and we
[ __ ] went across concrete and then we
stuck it in this [ __ ] thing and now
you can cut your postman's [ __ ] shoe
off with his foot still in it once again
I don't want to do a T stand up here but
how sharp is the [ __ ] dive dude I was
watching that commercial last night with
with the lovely Nia and we were just
laughing our asses off going I wouldn't
want that in my house I wouldn't I
wouldn't be I wouldn't feel safe with me
[ __ ] having a knife that should I cut
the [ __ ] tip of my finger of God
knows what some other lunatic okay no
civilian needs a knife that [ __ ]
sharp even those [ __ ] Dyson [ __ ] on
one of those cooking shows you know I
just wondered if that [ __ ] guy from
Hell's Kitchen ever realized how sharp
the [ __ ] knives are of the people
that he's screaming and yelling at you
know and I worked with enough [ __ ]
restaurants being one when I was growing
up to realize that people who work in a
kitchen for the most part are not the
most stable [ __ ] people [ __ ]
lunatics he's to work in this [ __ ]
restaurant one of the guys was on work
release meaning at night he went back to
jail
it slices it dices you can rob a bank
with it anyways I'm so [ __ ] happy to
uh I'm an old man now people I can't I
can't go on the road for that long you
know and now that I took the time to
build a personal life and have something
to come home to you know what I mean
I miss all the varmints running around
I'm a property taking out my slingshot
killing something before breakfast you
know that's one of my favorite things to
do go out in nature breathe it in feel
the peace and [ __ ] kill some skin it
look around making sure no other
predators coming around won't steal my
kill I remember one time I saw this
beautiful family of squirrels right
outside my breath cook my breakfast nook
something I carved out without a permit
and a little barren wall with ain't
nobody need to know that right now saw
his little family squirrels and the
mother was handing a little baby a
squirrel a little [ __ ] nut and right
before it handed it to her I blew that
thing's [ __ ] brains out made me feel
like an American I mean a little [ __ ]
was coming down you know I have a little
bird feeder and there was enough that
feeds for the birds all right and I
don't want to hear nothing about no
goddamn squirrel ain't no [ __ ] any
[ __ ] smart enough to realize that
bird food is bird food and and squirrel
food is squirrel food it just reminded
me you know when I saw that bird I'm
riding me to Isis and I was like what is
this little beady-eyed [ __ ]
doing and in the bird feed and I killed
it in front of its baby squirrel to send
a message to the other squirrels sorry
anyways did anybody watch any uh what do
i do what do i do want to talk about
first one sock Formula One racing you I
[ __ ] f1 you know what considering
it's always a weird call right now I
just talked about
varmints in your [ __ ] backyard which
is very American very patriotic
borderline a holiday right but I also
talked about Russian and Chinese people
buying [ __ ] you know top level
[ __ ] real estate Jesus bill can you
get it out but if they bought it in
America all right let's go f1f1 Oh Lewis
Hamilton Lewis the finger pointer
Hamilton one of the great drivers of all
time but oh that's that guy like to
[ __ ] point fingers when he doesn't win
a race oh my god he always goes you know
I don't know what happened you know I
don't really understand what the
strategy was there I'll have to find out
about that but you know racing is tough
he always does that maybe that's why
he's great it was a really really really
[ __ ] exciting race Lewis Hamilton had
the pole alright the [ __ ] race starts
Kimi räikkönen said you know what I
don't haven't won a race since 2015 I
think today's a good [ __ ] day to try
to win one and he comes to I don't know
what you know cuz I didn't see any of
the qualifying i fast-forward through
all the grid lineups and [ __ ] I thought
it was Vettel at first and when I saw
[ __ ] Vettel spin out
you only love about Vettel fettle and
Kimi raking and I love guys who drive
emotionally Sebastian Vettel what was
driving the way I Drive in [ __ ]
rush-hour traffic
he ends up spinning out [ __ ] up his
car then he just you know he doesn't
wave and go I'm sorry just slams on the
gas like he's [ __ ] Burt Reynolds
spins the car around keeps driving and
the guy managed to get all the way back
up to the front of the field to the
point that Lewis Hamilton needed to come
in second if he was gonna win yet
another championship
you know I tease Lewis Hamilton just
because you know it's not God don't
[ __ ] respect the guy but I you know
I'm new to this sport what am I am I
just gonna become a Lewis Hamilton fan
I'm I'm just gonna start watching
college football and who's your favorite
team ah Alabama I'm not [ __ ] doing
that I'm gonna root for LSU
[Music]
yeah you got to go contrarian so anyways
he had a chance everybody I think he
[ __ ] yeah he pitted early like really
early like on lap 12 of 56 I'm thinking
what the [ __ ] is he doing because no
matter what he does those tires are
gonna wear out so now he's in first
place he's driving like a lunatic cuz
he's trying to get enough [ __ ] space
between him and everybody else
specifically Sebastian Vettel because if
we basically I don't know I don't have
any [ __ ] points he needed I'm new to
the sport but he basically could have
won the championship that day so he's
driving like a lunatic while trying to
conserve his tires which never [ __ ]
works right
that's like staying in a relationship
because you know you got great sex but
there's no love there eventually you got
a [ __ ] you got to pull over just feel
like what what are we doing here so his
[ __ ] tires end up you know start
blistering like my shoulders in the Sun
they're like my gingered freckled
shoulders in the Sun so then he pulls in
and then the big thing is like [ __ ]
can he get out of the pits before Vettel
comes around so he can be in front of
him and he's got botas in front of him
Valtteri Bottas right and you know
Valtteri he's gonna [ __ ] do whatever
Louis wants him to do because evidently
he's the [ __ ] [ __ ] on the Mercedes
team I mean that guy's given away
literally a victory this year to keep
[ __ ] Louis happy and Louis is still
walking around going yeah you know I
don't know what happened that what do
mean you know what have what happened
there is everybody's catering to your
[ __ ] needs sorry you're gonna have to
wait another week before you win the
[ __ ] championship jesus [ __ ]
christ
somebody get this guy some sparkly
[ __ ] Kleenex over here right so
anyways he gets out of the pit before us
and Fennell does it's so [ __ ]
exciting my wife's going like wow this
is really interesting it's amazing I
can't get her to get into football
probably cuz again hit each other
anymore right but I think I might have
got her into Motorsports I said come on
yeah oh this is [ __ ] international
anyway but they have a race in Monaco
people pull up in yachts okay dad does
human trafficking going on in the bay is
the cars are going by and of course this
gets her excited because all she's
saying you know what she likes she liked
with Lewis Hamilton got out of the car
she goes wow he's really into jewelry
you know I had him I had it right there
it's gonna cost me a bunch of [ __ ]
money
so anyways
max max Verstappen whatever Lewis's
starts working his way up through the
[ __ ] field by the way Daniel Carter's
[ __ ] nightmare of a season continues
he's driving around he's having a great
[ __ ] time all of a sudden his car
quits like a [ __ ] Prius in the left
lane remember that rumor the thing just
[ __ ] dies and he pulls over and he
just get you to see mom
we were driving four [ __ ] Renault yes
next year can anybody explain to me why
that guy isn't gonna be driving for uh
for Ferrari next year because they were
trying to suggest that maybe Kimi
räikkönen's not give you I can't [ __ ]
believe how much I might know about this
sport I love it anyways so they get down
to the final five laps Lewis Hamilton
needs to pass max Verstappen if he does
that he'll have enough you know gap
between him as far as like you know I
think if that would have that'll come in
fourth maybe but with the points he
would have enough points to win and he
got to give it to Vettel and Ferrari
they're fighting to the very end they
like [ __ ] these [ __ ] [ __ ] where
Ferrari all right that's what everybody
[ __ ] once they want a goddamn Ferrari
and maybe if you're a little bit younger
you want a Lamborghini okay but really
if you really look throughout history
elegant styling power all of that you
got to give it to Ferrari you just have
to every kid at a [ __ ] poster magnum
p.i did he drive a Mercedes no he did
not he drove a Ferrari
okay people out there who got the first
hair plugs ever did they buy our
Mercedes
no they did not they bought a Ferrari I
don't what I'm talking about here
anyways all I know is when you go to
those make them [ __ ] you watch those
Meachem
car auctions it's not even like for like
actually Mercedes vintage Mercedes and
Ferraris there then I even act that
thing there at that thing that Jay Leno
goes to on that golf course up by
[ __ ] where the hell I mean that
that's like that's like people know
every nut and bolt on the [ __ ] car or
they have enough money to buy their
ex-wife [ __ ] three goddamn townhouses
stuck together in Manhattan ex-wife
right Pebble Beach I mean those cars are
so [ __ ] nice so goddamn expensive
they drive them onto the golf course at
Pebble Beach you know like you go into
the [ __ ] Rose Bowl so they had think
anyways Ferrari had a huge day I feel
you know can be raking him on his first
first race since 2015 Sebastian Vettel's
showing the heart of a [ __ ] line you
know you're gonna have to [ __ ] kill
me if you want to win this championship
and I don't know I probably had the best
thing was watching Lewis Hamilton trying
to pass past max Verstappen and Max for
snaps and holding them off right for
some reason by the way ESPN get out of
the [ __ ] car when that's going on you
know I thought what the [ __ ] am I
looking at here I'm in the gun I'm not
playing a video game how can I tell how
close they are if I'm [ __ ] sitting in
the goddamn car and I can't look in the
side view mirrors they did it on the
replay to anyways but I also love that
Lewis Hamilton liked how he had to make
sure that like I got to make sure this
guy doesn't [ __ ] spin me out you know
hitting my car then I'll be [ __ ] so is
this weird thing where he had to be like
super aggressive but also cautious it
was really exciting I don't lot of you
guys fast forward to any of that but I'm
so [ __ ] sold on that sport
I love it and I missed the [ __ ] I
don't know if there's a MotoGP think
about borders if Marc Marquez is [ __ ]
he's running away with the thing but
it's still some of the best racing and
next I'm next April I got a carve out
some time I want to go to that MotoGP
race in Austin but anyways let's plow
ahead here everybody it's the next thing
I wanted to talk about Oh we'll talk
about football here so yesterday the
only game I really watched was the the
Patriots versus the Bears because I only
got so much time on my day now and you
know I had to make up for that time I
was away and my my wife didn't tell me
when I was on the road was saying to my
daughter when she's at that age not she
was actually missing me like walking on
it's going Dada Dada Dada like wasn't
there [ __ ] broke my heart so anyways
I don't know so I got a I got a work
smarter is what I've learned so I was
just like all right this is football
Sunday I'm finally home so what I did
was I went out to breakfast my lovely
wife and my beautiful child and I just
taped the Patriots game and when my
daughter took a nap
I [ __ ] watch the Bears Patriots game
you know it took me like maybe like an
hour and 15 minutes to watch it because
I had the whole thing recorded up until
like the final five minutes and here's
what I would do if I was the offensive
coordinator of the [ __ ] Bears all
right that Mitch for Biscay I don't know
if I said his name right all right very
mobile quarterback and all of that but
at this point in his career
anything beyond 17 yards as far as if
it's like a pass he's he's not accurate
at all they haven't said that I remember
Tom Brady is secondly the second year
after he won the Super Bowl his deep
ball was not good okay I'm not saying it
was Mitch tri Biscay bad I'm just saying
he can get better at it the guy can
[ __ ] throw it 60 yards as we saw in
the last play of the game
he's just got to make sure that there's
somebody underneath it with the same
jersey it says so I didn't understand
why didn't they just dink
dunk their way down the field had that
Coen kid or whatever coming out of the
backfield he was killing us all day but
they kept trying to throw like a 20-yard
[ __ ] pass and like I gotta be honest
he was I mean really wasn't even close
should have dinked and dunk their way
down the field and occasionally just
send somebody deep have Mitch air the
[ __ ] thing out just to keep everybody
honest alright and then you can utilize
his eyes running ability because we
really couldn't stop the guy I tell you
what wasn't knowing what I really hate
is when a quarterback acts like they're
going out of bounds and everybody pulls
up and then the guy gets another 20
yards I think on the next [ __ ] play
you ought to be able to light the guy up
all right
it's a kunti [ __ ] move and everybody
flew up he's like he's Barry Sanders ya
know it isn't it isn't but one thing I
will say if haven't sat here and watched
the ridiculous level of celebrating that
goes on in baseball now and in football
especially in baseball like dude I don't
[ __ ] get it these guys hit doubles
and they're doing synchronized
celebrating with the people in the
dugout and back in the day you never did
that [ __ ] if you [ __ ] did that your
buddy who was batting next would be
looking at you like a UID a [ __ ] mind
and then he'd take one of the head
the pitcher just threw it the next
batter and it was just acceptable now
you got these guys they're going up
there they got the face guard they got
the elbow pad they got the shin guard
they're hanging all over the [ __ ]
plate I would just love to hear what
like Nolan Ryan would say about like
about that and then they're celebrating
they hit a single and they're doing
little [ __ ] jazz hands people the
dugout that point at each other they're
[ __ ] thumping their chest do you
think they just won the game that's what
kills me like who's that guy on the
[ __ ] Patriots I don't know anybody's
name anymore I got a kid right the
[ __ ] guy catches the football on a
kickoff I don't know what it was they're
like the score was like 10 to 3 some
[ __ ] like that 73 I can't remember
he runs up to about the 15-yard line
gets [ __ ] drilled coughs it up and
that other bears fit player by the way
just [ __ ] johnny-on-the-spot just
catches the ball and he gives him like
he coughs it up Bears get the ball at
the 15-yard line going and [ __ ] score
alright
absolutely totally [ __ ] up as the kick
returner and then either the next kicked
or a couple kicks later same guy catches
the ball he runs down the field goes all
the way for a touchdown slows down and
like the 8 yard line - high-five another
[ __ ] patriot before he goes over the
goal line as slow as humanly [ __ ]
possible he's sitting there high-fiving
like he's up in that game it's like dude
that just made you even you need to run
another one back and run into the
[ __ ] endzone I don't think they drive
me
he's got world-class speed yeah well
tell him to [ __ ] just stand on his
head maybe some of that world-class
speed will trickle down into his [ __ ]
brain stem that's like when [ __ ] trip
it ski was running all over the [ __ ]
field and then we finally sack him and
one of the Patriots does the shush thing
to the crowd like he's been doing it all
day that reminds me way back in the day
Jerome Bettis was the king of that
granted he's a [ __ ] hall-of-famer so
I'm probably wrong on this but I would
watch that guy and he would live like
thirty yards on 20 carries and then in
like the [ __ ] beginning of the fourth
quarter he'd finally ripped one off at
30 yards and then he get up and start
[ __ ] stopping around like you've been
doing it all day I guess it's just a I
think it's like a generation gap type of
thing I always liked the guys they score
a touchdown they give the ball back to
the referee you know I just feel like
everybody now is aware that if you make
a good play it's going to end up on
Instagram so you got it you got to throw
a little more [ __ ] mustard on it and
then maybe everyone
we'll forget about the the rest of the
[ __ ] game I have no idea
anyways plowing ahead here what do I got
here I'm trying to look for the [ __ ]
advertising here alright oh Jesus Christ
I didn't oh my god a Kate Upton thing
that I got was [ __ ] hilarious I
didn't realize she was married to
what's-his-face on the on the Houston
Astros anyways my bookie everybody my
bookie sure watching football is fun but
it's more entertaining when you have
some action on the games guys you heard
me talking about this for weeks and some
of you are still on the sidelines
whether you're an expert or rookie you
should be betting at my bookie if you're
the kind of guy that likes to bet a
little and win a lot like playing the
numbers on roulette you can create a big
parlay I don't know why they use that
roulette analogy you know when you
gamble you're actually trying to like
use your brain roulette it's like duh
big-block too many black bro
that red [ __ ] it bet green you know when
you bet on sports you got a system
anyways pick three teams to win and if
he hit all three could turn a hundred
dollars into six hundred dollars there's
so much to bet on playoff baseball
basketball hockey primetime fights and
more I recommend these guys because I
really trust them evidently my book my
book what the [ __ ] I never said that I
just read that my bookie has been in
business for years they've got great
online reviews and their mobile site is
easy to use my PO key is offering a
hundred percent bonus for the last time
this year that's right you've been
thinking about placing a placing a pick
all season but haven't manned up yet huh
you're not gambling what are you a
coward well it's time to make time to
make your move Jesus Christ after
Sunday's kickoff you can kiss the bonus
that bonus goodbye sorry people I left
my laptop at Baltimore which I know
sounds like a [ __ ] Tribe Called Quest
song
they left their wallet in El Segundo I
left my laptop in Baltimore
and it's being shipped to me so I'm
reading this off my phone and I'm matter
how big I make the font I can't read it
also make sure to follow at bet my
bookie on Twitter or Instagram they
personally respond to every mention in
DM not to mention that they've given
away nearly ten thousand dollars in free
money to their followers this football
season you'll be the first to know
as soon as new odds and props are posted
log on to my bookie right now don't miss
out on your last opportunity to collect
the industry's biggest bonus use promo
code BER and you'll get your first
deposit matched a hundred percent that's
promo code ber you play you win you get
paid or you lose you pay and you get
yelled at by your wife always got to
show you the other side of the people
all right MVM t movement has come far
from being crowd funded kids working out
of a living room well that's how to
broke college kids started a startup
they were crowd funded in the past year
they've not only introduced a ton of new
watches watch collections for both men
and women why did it say women and men
this is the male patriotical system in
advertising but also expanded to
sunglasses and fashion-forward bracelets
for her talk about your favorite new
style and it's featured suggestion
revolver collection well I guess they
look like guns talk about
entrepreneurship what it takes for a
company to reach exponential growth our
personal experience with it etc you know
you know I'm not smart enough to do that
move it watch it start at just 95 bucks
at a department store you're looking at
four to five hundred bucks movement
figured out that by selling online they
were able to cut out the middleman and
retail markup providing the best
possible price classic design quality
construction styled minimalism if
relevant talk about house a smart
watches overly intrusive on life with
notifications text messages emails etc
not not only that you just microchipped
yourself for the second time
well you Captain Kirk you just need to
know what time it is get 15% off today
with free shipping and free returns by
going to MVM t.com / / cy movement keep
growing check out their expanding
collection go to movement calm MV MT
calm / / join the movement oh look who's
tier everybody it's simply safe oh we
got a lot of them I'm gonna read this
one and then take a break don't go back
to the podcast simply safe home security
is home security that finally gets it
right simply safe started ten years ago
with the mission to fix the industry
they cut out contracts middlemen and
push these sales guys they made it easy
to set up your system with no handwrite
wiring tools minor hand wiring our tools
was simply safe you get professionally
monitored 24/7 protection for just $15 a
month that's your home protection by
police dispatch and fire dispatch
everyone loves this system everyone
loves it they love how it works and how
easy it is to use today simply safe
protects over 2 million people they've
one Editors Choice Awards from CNE t PC
Magazine and wire cutter go to simply
save / calm today to order your simply
safe system you get a 60 day risk-free
trial that's simply safe BER calm simply
safe BER calm si MP Li si fe b you are r
do TC om all right no you don't you know
you put in the dot right is that how it
works is that how it works
anyways plowing ahead here
what else did I want to talk about
looking at the notes on my phone did I
already lose it over now there it is
there it is there it is
so anyways I got to tell you so I took
we took our daughter to a pumpkin patch
yesterday which you know that's that's a
big mom dad moment for you first time
you take your kid to a pumpkin patch
right so my wife's going to go
when do you want to take her you want to
take her all right before her nap or
after I go a pumpkin patch seems more
like a fall you know afternoon type of
thing so she goes alright we'll do it
after so anyways we had gone to
breakfast in the morning and then we we
went to uh whatever she takes a nap so
now we're gonna go so we ended up going
to this really nice part of town and out
here in LA I don't want to out this
[ __ ] thing alright
they say it's a pumpkin patch okay now I
know I live in a [ __ ] city but at the
very least you know just try to [ __ ]
recreate some of soda patch we show up
to the goddamn thing it's in the parking
lot of a [ __ ] CVS they got a corner
of it there's a goddamn tent in there
and when I tell you they had four
thousand four thousand [ __ ] people
underneath that tent and this [ __ ]
giant woman who was she was like the
size of chief in One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest screaming at everybody
that they had to keep this area clear
it's clear what there's four thousand of
us in here they got [ __ ] goats and
they got a bed a petting zoo and this
like swear to god this little section
they threw some hay I got to give it to
him they threw some hay down over the
[ __ ] blacktop I'm in and I'm sitting
there like alright you know when life
gives you lemons lad going to the
[ __ ] pumpkin patch of a [ __ ] CVS
who gives a [ __ ] but my wife is sitting
there going like like you know this is
why women are awesome because they do
the holidays right you know she's they
just sitting there like you know this
isn't the [ __ ] this is not a pumpkin
patch but I will tell you this they had
some of the best pumpkins I've ever
[ __ ] seen the pumpkins were [ __ ]
ridiculous
they were the kind of pumpkins that if
there was a cookbook about [ __ ] he can
make out of pumpkins these were the
pumpkin they would make the cover these
were the Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
models of [ __ ] pumpkins so it wasn't
all bad
alright and that like six foot five
woman yelling and everybody was [ __ ]
hilarious because she was getting
frustrated but still trying to be nice
you know and she's into this [ __ ]
tent but goddamn head is almost touching
the top of the tent there was so much
and I didn't have any [ __ ] money
and somehow in there they had a little
ATM machine and I'm sticking my [ __ ]
credit my ATM card and they're going
like there's no way this isn't getting
double swiped there's no way some
Russian Baron isn't gonna try to [ __ ]
bison I don't know a [ __ ] pen and
pencil set for his ex-wife with whatever
the [ __ ] I have on my goddamn accountant
account so anyways she pulls the rip
cord she goes no no no no we're gonna go
to this other one so I'm like all right
no problem
cuz this is the new me I don't fight
this [ __ ]
all right I've just decided I'm gonna be
a better [ __ ] husband and I'm just
gonna argue less and when you really
make the decision that you're gonna be a
better husband they're the only real
option is you're just going to agree
with your wife that's really it - and in
a lot of women applauded that we're if
it went the other way like ladies if you
want to be a happy wife just agree with
your husband it would be considered like
really sexist and they'd be a kept woman
Stepford [ __ ] wife or whatever
elegant bridgeport it's some [ __ ]
town in Connecticut wife right Hartford
wife anyways Stanford Stanford wife is
that what it is I have no idea yeah you
just you just [ __ ] agree with them
alright and that's it makes it it makes
it better because that whole happy wife
happy life I mean it's really like it's
a joke I do on my act I go it sounds
cute because it rhymes but it's a threat
because it's literally if your wife
isn't happy nobody's gonna be happy and
that includes you your kid the [ __ ]
you if you got a goldfish it's gonna
start rolling over on its side like it's
starting to die until she gets into a
better mood again so it's just like I
okay let's just [ __ ] let's just keep
it happy
that's so alright so we drive over to
this other one and the old me would have
been like it's a [ __ ] pumpkin get
good [ __ ] pie there's a [ __ ] I
wanna watch the lake game yeah I would
have been the old me so I don't I just
do what my wife says and I get back in
the car right [ __ ] drive over the
other side of town does next pumpkin
patch so we pull into the next pumpkin
patch there's no place to park it's
[ __ ] crazy it's actually in a field
this [ __ ] rides there's a petting zoo
there's actually room for it right I'm
not a big petting zoo fan by the way all
right
all I'm thinking is [ __ ] what is it
hoof and mouth disease hoof and [ __ ]
goat horn dizzy whatever the [ __ ] it's
called right and not to mention they
bring the goddamn kids in there and
they're sitting there like walking up
they got no respect the parents for
these [ __ ] goats they've had their
horn sawed off so now they're standing
there right like like like Luke
Skywalker without his lightsaber though
he's just some guy in a bar you know I'm
a Jedi oh yeah let me see some Jedi [ __ ]
well you know I'd love to but you know
my lightsaber the battery
I got a recharge you just hang out for a
second I'll [ __ ] I'll have a sword
fight with somebody be impressed right
so we go in there and there's these
people they're just like their pet and
goats like their dogs and you see the
goats the goats they're [ __ ] annoyed
one of the guys goes up and he's just
stroking the beard of this one goat
where I'm just like you know I'm not in
the social circles of goats here but
that's got to be some high level [ __ ]
disrespect you know would you go into a
[ __ ] octagon at the UFC and start
tugging on the [ __ ] man bun or one of
those [ __ ] black belt Human Weapon
lunatics you wouldn't this is what they
were doing so my wife keeps telling me
to let my kid
pet the [ __ ] things and I'm like so I
just was holding onto her and I went
perpendicular to the goat you know if
it's an alligator
you want to come straight on cuz they
got to turn their head to the side to
[ __ ] bite you see go straight up and
just [ __ ] you know pet it on the snout
I mean if we're really gonna do white
people [ __ ] which is walk up to [ __ ] and
act like it's a [ __ ] dog when it
isn't that's basically what we do in
nature right so my see my wife getting
frustrated like I'm being a helicopter
parent I'm not I don't say that I'm like
all right you know what you [ __ ] do
it so she's she's bringing the kid in
like all the moms and they got the
[ __ ] goats eating this hay to try to
keep them happy and ignore the fact that
people are stroking that goddamn beards
right so all of these mothers are
approaching from the rear of the animal
and all I'm thinking is one of these
kids is gonna take a single or a double
[ __ ] leg kick from one of these
[ __ ] but one of these goats so I'm
sitting there trying to eat just [ __ ]
go from the side so fortunately nothing
happened and then all these people like
hey you want to go hit the food truck
it's like your kid just [ __ ] pedak
goat you're trying to get goat pinkeye
what do you mean what the [ __ ] are you
doing and they had chickens in their
chickens by the way they could tell that
this these chickens were just for the
petting zoo because they were regular
size cuz I was sitting there going like
wow look how look how small it sits
chested you know as a proposed to those
[ __ ] roided-up once you know what I
mean the pumping iron ones that are at
the grocery store anyways long story
show we [ __ ] before we get into that
we pulled into this this pumpkin patch
and there's no place to park and my wife
goes once they have a valet and I'm like
at a pumpkin patch like how what
happened to you that you want a valet
park at a pumpkin patch so we drive up
this hill way up this goddamn hill and
there's all these signs on the side of
the road that just say no parking fifty
dollar ticket and my wife's going like
it says fifty dollar ticket I'm like
what's the price
in business I'm what the [ __ ] do you
want from me and then I'm looking at it
and it's written on construction paper
with the magic marker and I'm like I
really don't think that's coming from
the city right there's all these other
people parked here nobody has a ticket
so we just parked so me me and Nia just
start laughing about this no parking
sign about how it's written on
construction paper with magic marker and
we're going down the hill and we end up
running into somebody that knew us that
got us in there was a super long line
and then we saw that there was actually
valet parking was like ah they wanted
they want to do the valet parking that
came from the valet people and the
regular parking so they could get your
money so you wouldn't park for free and
we ended up parking up so we went in
there we had the best [ __ ] time
people lost and they treated you like a
king can't think I'm not gonna you know
say the name of the [ __ ] place so
what I was feel weird out in that [ __ ]
but thank you so much for the way the
petting zoo was awesome I was just an
overprotective parent evidently we got
some awesome [ __ ] pumpkins I was
pulling my daughter around in the wagon
and she's at the age now when she wants
to walk but once she got in the wagon
she sat in the back corner and was just
chilling was leaning on one elbow and
she had her other arm [ __ ] draped
around like she was [ __ ] driving a
lowrider she absolutely loved it and I
got to tell you one of the great dad
moments of my life was pulling a wagon
with my kid in it with pumpkins all
around and I'm just thinking like you
know maybe that happy wife happy life
thing isn't a threat maybe they just
know when it comes to this [ __ ] the way
I understand I don't know some guy [ __ ]
so that's gonna be my new thing alright
you know if you want to buy 47 [ __ ]
pumpkins for the kid Halloween party
we're gonna have because it's going to
be great for their experience and you
know what we're gonna get 47 [ __ ]
pumpkins I'm done all right I'm not
going to pull a Lewis Hamilton here and
be like you know I don't know what
happened back there I mean
I think we only need one pumpkin some
reason we got 47 but uh you know I mean
but it's tough picking our pumpkins a
tough I'm not gonna do that she knows
what the [ __ ] best and we'll just
we'll just leave it at that we'll just
leave it to him I'm done I remember a
long time ago going to a cookout and
talking to another husband he just I
said so what'd you say what'd you say to
her huh what'd you say to him you know
some [ __ ] right he was just going ah
man he goes you know bill he goes I
don't have any more fighting me and I
was like at first puzzled but the
amazing thing was was I heard the piece
in his voice and and and him and his
wife seemed happy so I was just like all
right maybe the problem here is me maybe
because if the house was run the way I
was running it would look like a
bachelor pad and that's not what kids
need all right so I'm gonna shut the
[ __ ] up and make some pumpkin bread this
week and whatever my wife wants to do
I'm just gonna [ __ ] do it hug her
tell her I love her and I'm gonna try
that I'm gonna try that that road
rather than fighting every [ __ ]
goddamn thing and being a that [ __ ]
guy in one of those hacky Hollywood
movies about cops being that I'm getting
too old for this [ __ ] being that guy
ain't ain't not [ __ ] doing it anyways
alright well then another great moment
yesterday was when we left the first
pumpkin patch you know my daughter was
enjoying walking around so she was
crying because now she's back in the
[ __ ] astronaut seat and tried
everything I gave her my keys I gave him
my hat all of that [ __ ] and then that
wouldn't work so I just started singing
to her and then Nia started singing
along with me and then my daughter
slowly stopped crying and then was
trying to sing along we were doing the
you know where is pointer where is
pointer he
yeah Here I am and my daughter always
sings along to the run away like she
knows that part so we get through all
the fingers gets through where's where
is mama where is Papa
you know where's my daughter and then we
run out she's done crying and then we
just saying Old MacDonald had a farm all
the way to the next pumpkin patch which
was literally like a half hour away and
what was funny was we ran out of farm
animals and I was doing like penguins
and giraffes because my wife was Neil
was doing that the the sounds of the
animals and who the [ __ ] knows what a
what of giraffe sounds like so she would
be looking at me like you got really
you're gonna throw that in my lap like
the guy on second base celebrate and the
other guys at bat being like hey [ __ ]
I'm gonna take a 95 mile an hour
fastball to my [ __ ] chin guy over
here and you know what it was a great
goddamn day we didn't have any fights so
I think I discovered something all these
years of being with my lovely wife
evidently I was the problem and with
that let's do let's read some of the the
[ __ ] to read the emails here for the
wit this week alright bill great emails
Louie a Billy buttmunch oh my apologies
to Kate Upton I wasn't really trashing
her I just thought it was funny well I
feel like that's the last person I
thought would have chimed in I did say
that I thought it was cool that she was
a baseball fan said I just listened to
your Thursday podcasts your ears should
have been on fire I yelled like a wild
man keep reading you dumbass
keep reading while you were looking up
Kate Upton's bio if he only had read a
little more you would have discovered
Kate Upton is married to Justin
Verlander look at Justin Verlander
crushing it on the field and off he's a
starter and he's a close-up she's
married to him
is currently carrying their first child
take congratulations to them
but Justin I learned something happy
wife happy life alright so when she you
got major league ballplayer money and
she's got her money too so when she
wants 98 pumpkins which I also believe
is the speedy of fastball just you know
just grab a second third [ __ ] wagon
to just do what I'm telling you you love
the best day ever
anyways it's currently carrying their
first child so yeah she's she really
likes the Astros baseball
come on Billy bookworm don't make me
yell like that it's hard on my heart as
always go [ __ ] yourself alright I'm an
idiot I thought it was cool that you I
just thought she was a baseball fan
anyway I'm always doors
alright Michelin stars oh my god am I
gonna get trashed for everything I said
last week bill I was listening to you
Thursday afternoon podcast and heard you
bring up the Michelin stars for food and
I had the same reaction some years back
when I first heard about it
for those of you who didn't listen like
I thought Michelin stars was was
separate from Michelin tires like the
way a Macintosh stereo like the best
turntable one of the best out there
arguably is different from Macintosh
computers and it's spelled differently
but evidently it was the same people and
I'm like why am i listening to the
people who make radial tires so I don't
[ __ ] hydroplane tell me where I
should go get some beef boiling y'all so
anyways he said I had the same reaction
or she said back when I first heard
about it like wait it's the same guys
that do the tires so I had to find out
why a tire company became the standard
for fine dining
turns out the founders who are French so
I automatically love him started the
tire company in 1900 when there were
only about 3,000 cars in the entire
country
so to help drivers develop road trips
which would mean increased car sales and
also increased tire sales they started a
guide that included maps how to change a
tire where to get gas and places to eat
and sleep
eventually they bring
into fine dining in the 1920s or so this
has got to be the most informative and
interesting email I've gotten as far as
like correcting me the Kate Upton one
what might have been the most hilarious
considering all us real friends knew why
she was chiming in anyways one star
means it's a very good restaurant in its
category two stars is excellent cooking
worth a detour three stars is
exceptional cuisine worth a special
journey and I even think like that is
like all of those are the way they're
described are being extremely humbled
because if you get any star as far as I
am mean I don't too much about it but
like if you get three stars you're one
of the best restaurants in the world
so if you get one you're a third of the
best restaurant in the world I mean I'm
gonna [ __ ] eat there
anyways most restaurants don't even get
the one star so one star is pretty damn
solid there you go always sorry anyways
there is actually a one-star restaurant
right down the street from the Comedy
Cellar on MacDougal called Minetta
tavern oh I've eaten there
you've probably walked by this place
thousands of times if you haven't been
there it's definitely worth the stop in
think it opened in the 1930s not stuffy
or pretentious really old-school place
order the Black Label burger
I promised the burger and fries are
going to be excellent on I'm doing that
next time I'm in New York which I'm
gonna be when I play Madison Square
Garden on November 7th um anyways that's
the Michelin's story check out Minetta
if you haven't before hey you know what
these are two really great informative
emails I love it thank you very much
hey let me let me finish the last two
reads of the advertising here real quick
you guys want to hear me read out loud
you want to hear it be entertaining
again and then I'll go back to saying
dumb [ __ ] about stuff and then you guys
can correct me on the next podcast
Dollar Shave Club dude dude the [ __ ]
Red Sox are in the World Series dude
playing the [ __ ] Los Angeles Dodgers
you know usually they go to the World
Series I'm like [ __ ] if I was home I
would go now they're playing the team in
my hometown of goddamnit I'm gonna try
to go to one of those games and I will
be not I will not be wearing any Red Sox
[ __ ] because it's just not fun on the
west coast okay
there's no [ __ ] respect or anything
yet people try to kick the [ __ ] out of
you it's it's it's Philadelphia times
nine hundred I've had a problem at
Dodger Stadium I had a problem at a
Chargers game and I've only heard [ __ ]
nothing good about [ __ ] 49er or
Raider games and it's just like they
they just don't get it sports fans out
here really they just don't get it it's
just it's like violent and so I just I
just go there I don't wear any of the
[ __ ] and I just I just leave it at that
but like people out here just there's so
much [ __ ] that's great about out here
but the sports culture is [ __ ]
horrific so that's my warning to anybody
any Red Sox fan coming out here for a
Dodger game you know I'm not saying 100%
something's gonna happen but you know
it's kind of nice not to have brain
damage wouldn't you say I would just
leave you [ __ ] [ __ ] at home and
silently [ __ ] chair I dressed like a
[ __ ] undercover cop when I go to the
games out here right Dollar Shave Club
everybody Dollar Shave Club is
everything you need to feel and smell
your best and you never have to go to
the store oh by the way if you're the
[ __ ] [ __ ] who stands up in points
you know when you're in the employees in
opposing teams Stadium you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
alright that's because they deliver
everything you need right to you Dilla
and they keep you fully stocked on what
you use so you don't run out here's how
it works
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready no matter what you're
getting ready for they have you covered
head to toe for you heya your skin in
your face you name it they have it
and they have this new program where
they automatically keep you stocked up
on the products you use you determine
what you want and when you want it and
it shows up right at your door from once
a month to once every six months plus
with their handsome discount the more
you buy the more you save
and right now Dollar Shave Club has a
bunch of starter sets you can try for
just five dollars like their oral care
kit after that the restock box shifts
regular size products at regular price
get your starter set for just five
dollars right now at dollarshaveclub.com
/ / that's dollarshaveclub.com / / oh
look stamps calm everyone last read
lastly but not leastly stamps calm never
closes print postage for any letters or
packages at your convenience 24/7 print
postage for any small mail for any mail
class right from your own computer the
exact amount of postage every time never
under pay or over pay again
stamps.com saves you time and money
which you use to grow your business
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer stamps.com makes it
easy they'll send you a digital scale
that automatically calculates exact
postage stamps com will even help you
decide the best class of mail based on
your needs no need to lease an expensive
postage meter and there are no long term
commitments and right now you too can
enjoy stamps calm the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital sale scale go to stamps calm
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in bur that stamps
calm enter BRR alright back to the reeds
here um no not the reeds go back to the
emails all right here we go Kate Upton
Michelin stars car for high school kid
alright let's see this hey there Billy
Bronco hey well how about those new
Broncos that are coming back huh
look sweet I worked in a garage during
summers of high school in college not
only do you see what cars aren't [ __ ]
under the hood wait I worked in cars
I've literally went to the fantasy of
buying one of those Broncos and the
fantasy included my wife saying
absolutely bill get one you know what I
actually tried to talk her into was
letting me buy one of those old GMC RVs
from the 1970s into the 80s and I wanted
it in that Palm Desert green and I was
going to have the dude who built my
truck make this [ __ ] thing I was
actually considering have it be all
electric and then hiring a driver and
whenever I had a [ __ ] Road gig I just
had that thing driving around I'd fly to
where it was and do a run of gigs and we
would just be in there and we'd have a
[ __ ] humidor and a fridge for some
ice-cold beer and I put on [ __ ] nine
million pounds and my wife was just like
now yeah you're not doing that and I was
just like okay and it's good because I
swear to God if she didn't I would have
the [ __ ] that I would have you know what
I mean
I would I would argue that I would have
one of the weirdest [ __ ] car
collections ever because I would I would
own one of those I like station wagons
I'd have one of those [ __ ]
mercedes-benz AMG [ __ ] station wagons
you know what you know what one of these
days I'll actually I'll give you like my
top ten [ __ ] cars because I really
got to sit down and think about it I
like those [ __ ] those those GM member
look up GM General Motors parade of
progress and look at those those
whatever what the [ __ ] was that thing
called just look that up whatever that
vehicle was called it was like a [ __ ]
living room and a bus all at the same
time it had a spiral staircase that you
walked up the parade of progress check
that thing out anyways plowing ahead
here let me let me finish reading this
thing here
not only do you see what I would have
stretch limos from the 1950s I have a
1955 Chrysler Imperial stretch limo or
maybe one of those ones that like John
Lennon and Elvis had and world leaders
had that was made by Mercedes the 1960s
that really boxy looking one yeah all
weird [ __ ] I wouldn't have a Shelby
Mustang and a [ __ ] Hemi this and I
hand me that [ __ ] all that that's all
baby boomers [ __ ] I have no interest in
any of that stuff I like that [ __ ]
weird [ __ ]
I like those Nash I like that [ __ ]
BMW that had like three wheels and in
the whole front of the car would open up
he had to move out the steering wheel I
don't all [ __ ] like that now there's got
to be somebody out there with a car
collection like that that you can tell
me where I can go look at all those cars
because I love all of that [ __ ] man all
right my advice for the anyways oh the
kid the kid who wanted to buy the car
all right let's start over I worked in a
garage during summers of high school in
college not only do you see what cars
aren't [ __ ] under the hood but also cars
that look lame real fast
my advice for that kid is to get
something with low mileage from the 90s
jeeps lightweight pickups and anything
you can find parts for and anything
where you open the hood and the parts
are identifiable don't get a Dodge Neon
or a [ __ ] box find something that looks
new inside and inside and out get the
oil changed every 3,000 miles and have
it as long as you want it there you go
I used to do that I that's one of the
big things changing points when I was a
kid was I learned how to change the oil
in the car which is really simple but
it's huge I would do it every 2,500
miles I remember being in back east and
be freeze and [ __ ] cold out and he
had to do that thing where you know I
tried it the first time when the engine
was ice-cold and the oil was coming out
like syrup so you'd have to start the
car up let it run a little bit we had
heated up but not too much where all of
a sudden then it'd be [ __ ] hot but
even then that wasn't bad you just go
inside for like [ __ ] a half-hour
and I and I had a little place down by
the the firehouse that used to take the
recycled oil and I come down there I
dump the [ __ ] in there it was [ __ ]
beautiful
I learned how to changed the fuel filter
air filter is one of the easiest things
fuel filter uh got a grease gun the lube
job all that so you didn't get all the
squeaks and all that [ __ ] just basic
maintenance like that and then I would
bring it in I never learned how to
adjust a carburetor I always got nervous
with that [ __ ] and I would just I do all
that although however one time I got
impatient taking a fuel filter off and I
snapped it off of the [ __ ] fuel line
so then I had to get a tote over there
and I told the guy over there what I did
and he said I didn't communicate it
right and I had the fuel filter sitting
on the bench seat and he went out there
to start it up and gas went all over the
[ __ ] engine and we had a [ __ ]
engine fire that's when he said we had a
fire I was like no dude you had a
[ __ ] fire then he [ __ ] yelled at
me and [ __ ] and like I was gonna sue him
he goes look I'm not gonna start [ __ ]
doing a bunch of work on a goddamn car
with a hundred seven thousand [ __ ]
miles on it and just yelling I mean I'm
looking at the guy like dude I've been
bringing you this is my [ __ ] car over
here forever this how you gonna treat me
I'm not trying to be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but I didn't know how to say that to him
so I remember what my dad told me he
goes you go down there and you make sure
you pay so there's a record that your
car was there and not and sure enough I
went down and the guy said no charge
I said no I'll pay for it and he gave me
a look cuz he knew that I knew what the
[ __ ] he was doing unless the last time I
brought my car over there had it fixed
somewhere else and long story short at
one point I had an engine fire and it
[ __ ] burned down to the ground but
that was years later that was my first
vehicle 283 Ford Ranger anyways to be
honest the insecurity never came wait a
second well it's a different different
[ __ ] email oh okay so that's that's
that guy's suggesting he was too skinny
too tall here's the thing about the
insecurity bill I am what you would call
a goofy looking [ __ ] 511 like uh 135
pounds and
super-awkward I have a pretty face so
I'm told but I've always felt weird
about my body are you [ __ ] kidding me
if you got into fashion they tell you to
lose 20 pounds 511 135 you sound lean
and mean to me be honest the insecurity
never came from me but from other people
my earliest memory of yeah that's
probably their insecurity because you're
probably taller than a lot of guys my
earliest memory of being made to feel
weird about my body I'm assuming this as
a woman know they signed it Olive Oyl
all right my earliest memory of being
made to feel weird about my body was
when I was 8 and a teacher said I'm too
skinny and look weird yeah that's old
school [ __ ] people used to do that I
shot up in height since then and I've
always always been mocked for either the
height weight or both as a consequent
I've developed somewhat of a complex
about it
I've been suicidal about it before
honestly
oh Jesus Christ don't take it to that
level you got the supermodel body but
then I'll watch some video about a burn
victim and then feel like a real sack of
[ __ ] all right so you got some
perspective I'm a girl by the way forgot
to mention that and when I was in high
school I got bullied by this short guy
he said I was turning into a man once
and I honestly cried my eyes out Oh God
because you know what it is he's a
little [ __ ] runt and that's that's
the thing if if anything anybody in high
school listening to that like one of the
best things you can learn in life is
that so much so many things that other
people say really has nothing to do with
you even if they're saying it about you
it has to do with the other person and
how their parents suck or they feel bad
about their own life so you know like if
you want people to not say mean [ __ ] to
you walk around happy have a happy look
on yourself on your face like you know
go out and enjoy yourself and you won't
believe the [ __ ] negative attention
that you'll get and one of the great
joys in life is the day you realize that
it has nothing to do with you and you
to just filter all of that stuff out you
511 135 I mean I'm telling you like you
yeah there's there's a lot of women that
are gonna [ __ ] hate you because your
height and your build because it's gonna
be hard for them to keep weight off you
got a tremendous advantage everything
that all the clothes you're gonna put on
there's a reason why models are so tall
and all that because they look
absolutely stunning in the clothes and
then they sell it to all of all the
short [ __ ] people out there and then
they never look right anyways she said
my question to you is how do I get to a
point in life where you don't give a
[ __ ] what anyone says I get that I'm
thin but honestly it's just the weight
my body likes I'm not unhealthy at all I
have no health issues and my doctor
isn't worried yeah and in the older you
get you're gonna you're gonna look great
and all that that little runt who made
fun of you there's nowhere for it to go
except for his [ __ ] man tits what
should I do
next time someone says something to me
I'm 22 and people at work feel
comfortable enough to say [ __ ] like did
you have eating issues as a kid Jesus
cry even a complete stranger who is
asking for my help no less took it upon
herself to tell me I look anorexic yeah
no that's that's all other people's
issue I feel like people think they can
get away with [ __ ] like this because I'm
not fat you think I should just tell
people to [ __ ] off only thing is if I do
that'll be I'll be in an argument pretty
much 1 to 2 times per week thanks a
bunch and I love I love you and Nia wish
you and the Munchkin the best go [ __ ]
yourself olive oil alright you got a
great sense of humor just saying here
olive oil there's a bunch of [ __ ] you
can do alright I don't know one of the
things I used to do when I used to go
out after shows and when somebody said
like mean stuff to me I would just go
you got something between your teeth and
they never did right but
it would just make them so
self-conscious they'd immediately shut
their mouth and put that tongue up over
their teeth and then just [ __ ] walk
away you can do that and just say I
appreciate that and just you know offer
them a piece of gum you know make it
seem like they have bad breath
there's little things like that to turn
it back around on them I don't I don't
you know you know what really what it's
really going to be because then you know
I'm also suggesting that you kind of be
mean to them what you're gonna have to
do is just you know learn to like how
you look that's it and just really know
that that's all about them and I know
you're at work but you know if a guy
said something to you I mean it's easy
to be like just be like you know I
recently heard that a lot of things that
people say mean about you has nothing to
do with you it has to do with them
that's too long
just be like sir are you saying that to
me cuz you're actually concerned or is
it because your dick is the size of a
[ __ ] peanut I don't know what the
[ __ ] you can go with dick size that's
always good alright this is some old
schoolyard bully [ __ ] just go with the
obvious they're going with the obvious
on you oh you can talk about my weight
then I can talk about that giant [ __ ]
potato you call a [ __ ] nose in the
middle of your face you know you know
it's gonna keep growing your ears your
nose just keep growing you're gonna look
like Jimmy Durante by the time you're 35
you don't know who the [ __ ] he is we'll
look I'm up your [ __ ] now yeah what I
don't know I mean I'm gonna give you
stand up line so you can't say him at
work if some woman said you'd said you
are you anorexic and just say no I just
know how to push myself away from the
table you pudgy [ __ ] you know there's
that you can do that but I think it's
really more important to just accept the
fact that here's the thing your
metabolism will slow down as you get
older you'll fill out a little bit more
and you know I mean it when I was 22 I
was a [ __ ] rail myself and now look
at the beautiful bald Adonis that I am
now at 50 I don't know
I started losing my hair I didn't go out
and [ __ ] you know try to start moving
[ __ ] around up there I just said [ __ ] it
I shaved my head I just am Who I am and
you know people call me a bald cut now
and it makes me laugh I actually take it
as a term of endearment I like how I
look and I die no I'm not you know I'm
not a good-looking guy but I I [ __ ]
it I like that I look like a [ __ ]
freak it's fun and I actually enjoy
aging I bought this [ __ ] old man
sweater the other day and my wife goes
white you can't put that on you look
like you're [ __ ] an old man I go I am
an old man let me be an old man and wear
my old man's sweater put around the
house and [ __ ] sit on the back porch
smoking a scar thinking of your 22 years
old you got your whole life ahead of you
you're gonna run into somebody's gonna
realize how [ __ ] beautiful you are
and I gotta admit something the fact
that everybody gives you [ __ ] about the
way you look you're gonna have a great
sense of humor and you're gonna laugh a
lot in life and that's gonna keep you
young so god bless you and your 511 body
135 pounds and everybody else can go
[ __ ] themselves and with that that's the
podcast and the rest of you can go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check in on ya on
Thursday